can I ask the two of you what you did to
prepare for these kinds of roles I know
that I saw in an earlier interview you
had gone to the zoo and watched caged
animals to see what it was like to be in
the hole oh yeah I but I also spent us
after noon in solitary confinement which
was really interesting
I knew I could I was going to get out
but I tried to you know get the
sensorial experience somewhat and talk
to prisoners talk to guards but you know
I think Morgan would agree that
imagination is the key and you have to
imagine whatever you experienced it 300
times worse you know to be in for such a
long time and what that does to your
spirit and how can you hold on what do
you hold on to you know digest for you
the script that's a process and I knew
he was going to say
can can either of you tell me about
since we talked about the hail and the
tornadoes and the heat what what was the
single hardest day of shooting for
either one of you
oh I know what Tim's gonna say I don't
know what you think I'm gonna say what
am I gonna say I don't I don't what one
would it not have to be and you were
such a sport about it but when you came
out of the pipe into the creek oh yeah
that was hard yeah see uh that was tough
that was until rivers around there where
this was this was cow country yeah yeah
enough set right wasn't actually human
[ __ ] it was cow [ __ ] then yeah they were
pretty it was pretty toxic but you know
we get had a nice shower yeah from the
above thank God no laughter Morgan a
particularly bad day
oh we're tougher uh well Frank made me
laugh about 25 or 30 minutes and then
didn't use it
oh no they do and you did it really well
by the yeah you did it really well that
was actually a perfect lead-in I think
next question I was going to ask you
Frank that I know I've watched certain
deleted scenes I understand that you had
an amazing scene of the nervous
breakdown when you were doing your job
and you knew you couldn't make it on the
outside and if you haven't seen it you
really should he has this panic attack
where he goes into the men's room and
just collapses in this storm of anxiety
so there were there was a little bit
left on the cutting-room floor I was
wondering if you could talk about what
that meant and also what it meant to
tell this to the actors well I never
told them they still don't know no what
we're really what it was there was a one
thing that that we hate is is is
sometimes the most instructive night of
your life which is the test screening we
hate the test screening it's awful it's
miserable except it will always teach
you something about your movie that you
really need to know I'm sure that you
guys have both directed you've probably
experienced the same thing for me it was
this after his character gets paroled
the audience wanted him to get to that
tree and answer the question for them of
what's buried there as quickly as
possible and I had shot this five
minutes of a really cool movie that was
getting in the way of that including
this this marvelous scene and that
Morgan did so beautifully of the nervous
breakdown in the in the he's having this
massive panic attack in this little
market where he's working as a parolee
and and he has to run into the into the
men's room and the bathroom and closed
the door and get into the smallest stall
to feel the walls around him it was
wonderful stuff but for those five
minutes you're really sensing the
audience getting impatient because they
already believed us we didn't have to
prove that he was going to may not make
it on the outside because he himself
said he wasn't going to make it on the
outside and and when he says it they
believed it
and we had already laid all that
groundwork with Jim Whitmore earlier in
the movie so we knew what that
experience was we didn't have to relive
it again so the first thing we did a
Richard Francis Bruce my editor and I is
Richard here tonight gosh I wish he were
here it's a shame he's not was we
couldn't wait to run back to the editing
room and and and pull that five minutes
of movie out because it was just really
getting in the way you heard that right
couldn't wait to get rid of it couldn't
wait but not wait to get ready
sorry Mark the night Frank made Morgan
Freeman cry at the Academy go down to
history